the biggest thing for me was that i was
very good at the candidate side i think
it's again it's like a bit of a myth
like a lot of people come into the
industry and of course you know clients
are hugely important like you have to
have clients but i found myself to like
if i was candidate led and candidate
focused then the clients would also come
and they'd be happy as well you can have
all the clients in the world but if you
can't deliver on that candidate side
then
it's not going to work and i think what
i did very well was where i believed
that i really understood what the
candidates wanted i would have really
in-depth conversations with each
candidate but i would quickly know in
the first five minutes by asking a few
good questions what really makes this
candidate tick if this candidate they
have all the skills but if this
opportunity that i'm trying to offer
them isn't right for them they're never
going to take it and there's no point
trying to put a square into round hole
you know so that's what i teach for my
team now is you know from the first
phone call like you have to get a really
good idea what the candidate wants what
really makes them tick and it's much
more difficult i think in this day in
our tech market the candidates have so
much choice but yeah i think it was my
focus on the candidate side and really
trying to give them a genuine service
and understanding where i should put my
time that is key if you have loads of
half-hour conversations with candidates
that never really end up anywhere you're
not going to achieve what you want to
achieve by prioritizing okay this
candidate is super invested this
candidate really wants this job i can
control the situational influencer they
should get your time if you have a
candidate who really isn't invested but
maybe the client likes them or they're
really highly skilled like they still
have your time but maybe not so much so
i think time management's really really
crucial and i think another thing in
hindsight i don't think i really knew
this at the time but one thing that made
me stand out to clients i think was they
could trust me i had a very different
approach and i think i was memorable as
well because of my speech perhaps
because of the fact that i could speak
some german to my clients as well and i
would just try different things and i
think a big thing especially when you're
beginning in this job it's so easy to do
what everybody else is doing it's what
makes you memorable that sticks in
someone's mind you need to get a client
to when you call them to go ah it's john
yeah i know you cool you helped me last
time or you gave me some good advice i
think it's being memorable it's really
really really important the recruitment
mentors podcast is proudly sponsored by
vincerie and the award-winning sauce
breaker
[Music]